طلعت ما لئه الدنيا وشاغله الناس انها
منصه تشات
منذ طرح النسخه العامه في اواخر العام
الماضي من هذه المنصه التي ابتكرتها
الشركه الامريكيه اوبن اي اي المملوكه
لمايكروسوفت تجاوز عدد المشتركين فيها
مليون في خمسه ايام فقط معا انبهار
المستخدمين بما يمكن ان تفعله
وتعمل شركه اوبن اي اي حاليا على تحديث
الاصدار الرابع من تشات جي بي تي بتقنيه
احدث واقوى اثارت اعجاب المراقبين بقدرتها
على القيام بمهام كالاجابه على اسئله عن
الاشياء بالصور والدردشه التفاعليه وتعد
الامكانيات التي توفرها انظمه الذكاء
الصناعي الان مذهله وفي بعض الحالات وثيره
للمخاوف هذه المخاوف مفاتيح يعبر عنها
مالك تويتر والرئيس التنفيذي لشركه تسلا
للسيارات ايلون ماسك الذي قال ان مجال
الذكاء الصناعي يوتره وضع الى تنظيمه
وضبطه ماسك من بين شخصيات رئيسيه في هذا
المجال تريد تعليقات تجريب انظمه الذكاء
الصناعيه المتطوره لقد وقعوا خطابا مفتوحا
يحذرون فيه من المخاطر المحتمله على
البشريه ويقولون ان السباق لتطوير انظمه
هذا الذكاء لم يعد منضبطا حصل الخطاب
الصادر عن منظمه في لايف على اكثر من الف
توقيع لوقف تطوير الذكاء الصناعي المتقدم
واخضاعه لضوابط السلامه والتدقيق من قبل
خبراء مستقلين
يقول معهد فيتو لايف انه منظمه غير ربحيه
مهمتها توجيه التقنيات التحويليه بعيدا عن
المخاطر الشديده ونحو افاده الحياه ويدرج
ايلون ماسك كمستشار خارجي للمنظمه تحذر
الرساله من ان الذكاء الصناعي يمكن ان
يغمر قنوات المعلومات بمعلومات خاطئه
ومضلله
ويستبدل الوظائف بالتشغيل الالي تاتي
الرساله في اعقاب تقرير حديث صادر عن بنك
الاستثمار ساكس الذي قال انه بينما من
المرجح ان يزيد الذكاء الصناعي الانتاجيه
يمكن ان تصبح ملايين الوظائف اليه
كما اثرت اسئله من قبل مشرعين امريكيين
بشان تاثير هذا الذكاء على الامن القومي
والتعليم وحذرت وكاله الشرطه الاوروبيه من
خطر استخدام مجرمين لنظام جي بي تي في
عمليات احتيال او ارتكاب جرائم الكترونيه
او التظليل